[Music]
today we can grow giant models for foot
in a month the 45 inches
these models would taste exactly the
same as a normal model nice intend
unless some of them look a bit tough but
once you cut into them they cut like
butter my name is Philip pounds I live
in tonari Wales and I grow giant
vegetables I've been growing giant
vegetables now for the last 30 years I
come from a very large family my mother
attempting children 13 of us survived
and I think that was something you know
big vegetables feed big families you
know I'm up um every morning every night
every single day of the week there's a
lot of love and care goes into it
sometimes I do able to talk into them as
well to encourage them to grow which is
a bit of an bit of fun you know I think
we just about finish grow in there now
I've got to be very careful the wife is
not a vocal and I start talking to my
vegetables but this all good fun I broke
the world record for the area's cucumber
what 25 years ago it radiates in a half
pound and it was just incredible the
weeks you you know when I started if we
had a model 20 30 pound in weight you
are the base model now we're up over
hundred pound in weight
normal cabbage would be 2 pound in
weight but we are growing 120 pound you
know you can feed 120 hundred 340 people
off one cabbage this is why I supply the
local pub and they use them a present
day lunch I developed my own strain more
or less now I select my own seed every
year the biggest and the best seed and
it just seems to be improving which is
incredible I grow all chronically I just
think if I can do it anybody can do it
and it's a big thrill everyday the wife
say what am i doing up allotment every
day and when she comes up she realized
[Music]